nevada lawmakers have wrapped up the
legislative session in carson city just
before the midnight deadline several
bills cleared legislative hurdles
lawmakers legalized cannabis lounges and
a public health insurance option that
would be run by the state
lawmakers also passed changes to how
we're going to be able to vote
first with this changes to voting nevada
is going to switch from
caucuses to primaries and that'll be
taking
in effect february of 2024 it'll
basically be how we voted in the last
election
will become law which means you can
still vote in person
but you'll have to opt out rather than
opt in to getting a mail-in ballot
we believe that as a as a constitutional
right people should have
every option to fully participate and
there are others that think it's more of
a privilege
well it's a constitutional right
additionally mining companies across
nevada will face a new excise tax
and that money will go to public schools
another big item moves
another big another big item rather is
the right to work
law that means most tourism workers who
were laid off in the pandemic now get
their jobs back